[Music]
in 1838 the german educator friedrich
frobel
laid the foundations of modern education
when he opened the play and activity
institute
freuble soon called his institute a
kindergarten
reflecting his belief that young
children should be nurtured
and nourished like plants in a garden
proble who studied under the swiss
educator johann pastelozi established
the idea that
games and playing are typical and
essential forms of life
activities in the kindergarten included
singing
dancing gardening and self-directed play
quality time spent like this was a
considerable improvement to the life of
many children
given that the alternative was often to
help parents with work
he also introduced the concept of fry
arbite
which can be translated into free work
during set periods of time children were
allowed to work on things by themselves
when many adults saw pointless play
freuble saw
important learning taking place while
practicing their concentration skills
and resilience
the children also learned about
engineering logic
and physics
[Music]
to help facilitate this process he
developed a set of
educational toys known as freuble gifts
the set contained 20 objects such as
balls
blocks and sticks freuble carefully
designed the toys to help the children
in his kindergarten
recognize and appreciate common patterns
and forms
found in nature
his innovative ideas soon found appeal
and many young educators came to learn
from frebel
and to see the immense potential
displayed by children at his institute
later many of rebel students opened
their own
kindergarten and germany experienced a
rapid growth in the numbers of
early childhood centers then something
bad happened
after suppressing the german revolutions
of 1848 to 49
the prussian government started a
crackdown on new
democratic ideas and women were
forbidden from being politically active
the fact that some were operating a
kindergarten all by themselves
was seen as problematic
and so it didn't take long for the
government to label freuble's
kindergarten ideas as dangerous to both
the state
and church soon all schools that
followed for rebels principles were
banned
for frebel who saw his life's work
destroyed
and the future of all the children
disrupted this was a terrible blow
he died in dismay just a year later
but the ban caused a diaspora of
kindergarteners who could no longer work
in germany
spreading frebel's ideas all over the
world
one of froble students founded the first
kindergarten in the united states in
1856
but the story didn't end there
[Music]
exactly 20 years later a young woman
named anna lloyd jones stumbled upon a
set of frebel's gifts
at a visit to the first world's fair in
the united
states anna a teacher by training
was so excited by the wooden toys that
she bought a set for her nine-year-old
son
little frank loved the toys his mother
brought home
and began building all kinds of
geometrical structures
first with the wooden toys later in
miniatures and with other materials
without formal training frank lloyd
wright became one of the world's most
renowned
architects responsible for some of the
most iconic buildings in modern
architecture
many of which resemble freuble's toy
blocks
germany lifted its ban on kindergartens
in 1860
realizing that it was a terrible mistake
and while freuble wasn't around anymore
to witness the rebirth of his ideas in
his homeland
they continued to spread around the
world and became an
inspiration for maria montessori rudolf
steiner
and many others who set out to innovate
formal education
[Music]
freuble once said that play is the
highest
expression of human development in
childhood
for it alone is the free expression of
what is in
a child's soul frank lloyd wright
described the influence of such play on
his approach to design
as follows for several years i sat
at the little kindergarten tabletop and
played
with the cube the sphere and the
triangle
these smooth wooden maple blocks all are
in my fingers to this day
how was your experience with play and
learning when you were young
did you go to kindergarten and what are
your thoughts on play as a medium for
growth and development
share your thoughts to download this
video without background music
or to learn more about the topic visit
[Music]
sproutschools.com